it's Gran Turismo a green light for
other PlayStation game adaptations
here's a breakdown of the film's high
octane final lap and what it could mean
for a possible franchise
before we race the film's finale let's
recap the biggest moments leading up to
it after Nissan executive Danny Moore
gets approval to create the competition
series GT Academy and recruits bitterly
retired racer Jack Salter he starts to
pick out competitors from across the
globe British hope for Jan martinborough
joins a competition after earning a spot
in a virtual qualifying race although
Yan and his fellow competitors are
hopeful that their dreams will become a
reality Salter gives them a reality
check through some harsh but necessary
training despite soldier's tough
training methods that push everyone to
their limits Jan is not only able to
improve his skills But ultimately comes
out Victorious by the narrowest of
margins before being able to join the
ranks of the world's top Racers though
yamasa and his professional license and
contract with Nissan by placing fourth
or higher in a qualifying series
although Yan's first race doesn't go
well he subtly improves and is
eventually able to place high enough to
earn his license and starts his
professional career shortly after
signing his contract with Nissan Jan
enters his first race and even though
things start well it ends in disaster
Yan's car unexpectedly flips in the air
and crashes into a spectator section
accidentally killing a spectator this
tragedy causes Jan to blame himself for
what happened and give up racing
altogether
well there's salt to resist doubts about
Jan and his fellow competitors his
ability to actually compete to
Motorsport he slowly starts to see how
capable they are especially Yan by the
time Jan earns his professional license
Soldier completely believes in him and
is arguably his biggest supporter not
afraid
you should be after Yan's accident
though Soldier is crushed by Yan's
decision to quit racing Salter
ultimately decides to reach out to Yan
and take him for a drive back to where
the accident occurred there he finally
tells Yama caused him to stop racing and
it turns out that is similar to what Yan
is going through salsa was also a part
of a tragic accident at the peak of his
career which caused the fatality that he
was never able to shake like Yan even
though people told solter that it wasn't
his fault he was never able to fully Let
It Go and it caused him to struggle to
get back into the driver's seat to this
day Soldier still regrets it and doesn't
want to see Yan go down the same path
solita's story ends up inspiring Jan to
not only reignite his racing career but
also achieve the dreams that were cut
short for Salter
although Yan is ready to return to
racing Dany gives him some unfortunate
news while Yan isn't seen as responsible
for the accident others would rather
have him no longer race most of the
other drivers have signed a petition to
keep simulation races like Yan from
competing causing some of Yan's sponsors
to consider pulling their support with
Jan not wanting to quit he comes up with
a way for them to prove that he belongs
by placing on the podium at the 24 Hours
of Le Mans with a team of simulation
Racers Soldier and Dany agree with yarn
and call for two of his GT Academy
adversaries to race alongside him in a
three-man team before the race starts
Jan is also able to reconcile with his
father gaining the support and
acceptance he's yearned for Yan
struggles early in the race after
witnessing another driver crash but with
the help of seoulter reminding Yan of
what he's driving for he's able to get
in the right headspace despite some
issues with the pit crew Jan is able to
fight back in the race and ultimately
lead his team to a third place finish
cementing their place in history and
squashing any doubt of their ability to
perform
shortly after Yan and his team celebrate
on the podium the film delivers some
small tidbits about Yan's real life
career and involvement with the film
alongside some photos of Yan's real
experience competing in GT Academy and
driving professionally the film
acknowledges that Janus competed in over
200 races and earned many achievements
in his career as an added bonus a film
even tells viewers that Jan actually
acts as a stunt double for agda Archie
madekui in the film however the bigger
question is how much of what we see in
the film is true to Yan's real life
story while certain characters like Jack
Salter are solely made up for the film
the events of the story are pretty
accurate but somewhat told out of order
for instance a catastrophic accident
that caused Yan to crash into a field of
Spectators actually happened a couple of
years after he plays third at Le Mans
also he didn't rate alongside other GT
Academy graduates at Le Mans he raced
with them at the spa 24 hours instead
I've been cynical as well because I
think the kids that sit in front of TV
screens playing you know motorcycle
games where maybe you call them so even
though Yan's story in the film is
inspired by actual events in Yan's
career rather than wholeheartedly based
on them Gran Turismo does its best to
pay tribute to the achievements and
impact Jan has had on the Motorsport
world
one of the biggest debates throughout
the film is whether simulation players
can hack it on a real track much easier
with a joystick isn't it
that question is what drives Daddy to
create GT Academy and causes salsa to
openly doubt all the participants at the
start of the competition Yan is at the
center of this debate as well he's
trying to prove his critics wrong and
show that The Gran Turismo Community
should be taken seriously there are
major hurdles for Yan and other GT
Academy competitors but he eventually
puts his Deltas in check when Jan enters
a world of professional racing he's
quite a force to be reckoned with he
continually improves his craft and
impresses people in his first race even
though it doesn't end in Victory Jan is
living proof that simulation and video
game skills can translate to reality and
be a stepping stone for someone wanting
to be involved in the real thing moments
including Yan knowing parts of the cast
also didn't expect him to and
understanding how to make passes on
turns are great instances of the game
connecting with reality
that was actually pretty great the film
further gives the Gran Turismo community
and really every Sim Community a voice
and shows that they are very capable of
turning their virtual passions into
reality
as much as Gran Turismo is a positive
message about chasing your dreams it's
also a bit of a cautionary tale sure
there's a lot of heartwarming success in
Yan's Journey but it doesn't overshadow
how the film highlights the dangers of
Motorsport before Jan even starts his GT
Academy Journey Salter makes it clear
that students could potentially die if
things go wrong he even says that there
would be no shame in quitting and that
he wouldn't let anyone he didn't believe
in sit in the driver's seat at first it
seems like an intimidation tactic from
salsa but it quickly becomes clear that
he's not wrong the crash is in Gran
Turismo prove how vicious and genuinely
deadly Motorsport can be one wrong
twitch during a turn or slight
hesitation can lead to the driver's
death and the deaths of other drivers
and Spectators Jan experiences this
multiple times throughout the film he
sees a fiery crash at Le Mans but the
driver miraculously survives and he
himself was involved in a crash that
accidentally kills a spectator even a
psychological trauma drivers can suffer
from is just as horrifying Gran Turismo
doesn't shy away from the danger and
potential tragedy of Motorsport
at its core Gran Turismo is a sports
Underdog Story meant not only to one
viewer's heart but also to inspire them
to pursue their passions like any
Underdog Yan faces as fair share of
adversity from his father disapproving
of his aspirations becoming a racer and
Soldier doubting his ability throughout
his time at GT Academy there wasn't much
support for Yan plus he has to face and
ultimately beat his GT Academy
competitors who were equally as talented
even when he finally earns his chance to
race in professional circuits he's
looked down upon by other drivers and is
forced to deal with an accident that was
beyond his control yet Jan constantly
perseveres and overcomes the obstacles
in front of him through a sheer
determination he always finds ways to
push Beyond his limits and impress
anyone who doubts him his father and
Soldier are certainly impressed by his
drive and ultimately become his most
pivotal supporter is what makes Yan
leading a landmark performance at Le
manso meaningful audiences have been
with him every step of the way Gran
Turismo is a classic Sports story with
Underdog Vibes that remind viewers that
everyone's dreams can come true no
matter how big or small buy more video
games and you too could become world
famous
the film ending on Jan martinborough's
legendary performance under 24 Hours of
Le Mans actually holds more meaning than
you'd think at the start of the film
Janis raising his friend online in Gran
Turismo on the lemon track
I know this track so confusing in the
real life endurance race in the finale
brings his journey full circle Jan and
his team placing third at Le Mans is
arguably one of his most notable
achievements in his real-life
professional career It Was a Race that
really put him on the map and helped him
break away from being looked at as the
GT Academy winner Leman being the
setting for the film's finale is also
meaningful for fans of the sport and
general fans since the race has an
iconic Legacy in the sport the 24 Hours
of Le man is easily one of the most
well-known and highly regarded events in
the racing world as explained in the
film placing there solidifies you as a
legend in the sport so it's a setting
that elevates the meaning behind Jan and
his team trying to get SIM Racers like
themselves the respect they deserve
so often these days when a big name
movie premieres audiences wonder if it
has franchise potential at this point
Sony hasn't made any announcements
regarding a sequel to Gran Turismo and
honestly there probably won't be one the
movie is based on the real life story of
Jan martinborough and not strictly on
the game though a sequel could focus on
Yan's career after his origin story that
seems unlikely another potential could
be a movie that focuses on another
driver with a similar background even
more interesting to be a follow-up that
is completely original and not based on
an actual racing figure but the fact
that Gran Turismo is a biopic makes it
unique in the world of video game movie
adaptations so a fictionalized follower
probably doesn't make sense for a
potential sequel however if Sony's new
movie does well at the box office you
can expect that at least one executive
will look for ways to bring the Gran
Turismo name back to the screen for
another lap around the track
all those Sony and Playstation have
shown interest in turning their movie
and TV adaptations of video games into
successful franchises the ending of Gran
Turismo say something different while we
already know that a second season of The
Lassa versus coming and that the endings
of Enchanted and Twisted Metal into
potential Futures Gran Turismo is an
adaptation that feels complete the
ending highlights Yan's success in the
film and in real life and doesn't
suggest that there's another story to
tell since it seems like Sony isn't
trying to establish a big cinematic
future for Gran Turismo it suggests that
we could see smaller adaptations in the
future PlayStation games like concrete
Genie ape Escape Shadow of the Colossus
or maybe even patapon could get big or
small screen adaptations one day prior
to Gran Turismo we expected that
PlayStation would try to turn all of
their adaptations into robust franchises
but Gran Turismo changes that narrative
with its ending and opens the door for
more potential adaptations
foreign